les investisseurs veulent toujours
davantage l'incertitude économique les
certitudes sur les marchés la pandémie
les tensions entre les états unis la
chine tout cela ça fait grimper le prix
du métal précieux à de nouveaux sommets
j'en discute avec daniel racine qui est
président directeur général de yamana
gold l'une des grandes sociétés
aurifères canadiennes
bonjour monsieur racine bonjour monsieur
book si certains doutaient encore que
lors des fois une valeur refuge alors on
devra se raviser c'est que votre regard
sur les dernières semaines disons que
c'est une eau chez xiam ah non on est
content chaque augmentation depuis lors
nous a aidé énormément dans la gestion
de nos opérations nos projets actuels et
futurs remettra à nos actionnaires qui
ont été patients dans les dernières
années des dividendes mais plus élevé
c'est ce que quelques prix de l'or a
augmenté beaucoup depuis le début de
l'année depuis un an de 36 pour ça donc
c'est quand même assez important
et puis on ce qui me concerne a augmenté
son centre à l'or qui est en 2011 à 1921
sont indécents dans l'ordre aujourd'hui
devrait être de ça donc on voit qu'il ya
encore du chemin à faire pour se rendre
où ce qui était assez à ce moment là je
vous parlais du prix de l'eau jusqu'à
2200 l'oeil est tout près de 2000 et
j'ai même vu des analyses qui parle de
l'once l'or à 3000 $ alors si
l'incertitude économique certains sont
allergiques ce n'est pas votre cas vous
le nom c'est pau c'est pas notre cas
nous du tout c'est sûr que
l'augmentation quand le prix d'or
augmente ça veut dire que de leurs
américains bikes et c'est souvent
inversement proportionnelle à un autre
et ça c'est une ça donne un signal aussi
que savoir plus ou moins bien dans le
monde
malheureusement mais pour nouveau cc cc
ça ça va bien c'est qu'on l'a d'ailleurs
puisque vous avez parlé notamment donc
de 2011 c'est à ce moment là qu'on avait
vécu donc un sommet qui étaient
similaires s'étaient tout de suite après
la crise financière également
exactement disons que c'est un peu le
corps présentement même avant la
pandémie
il y avait beaucoup d'indicateurs vous
avez mentionné au début et bas taux
d'intérêt
le nom les relations entre la chine et
les états unis la dette qui ont augmenté
de façon importante
et puis la pandémie tout ce qu'elle a
fait du sport dès 19 heures juste
accéléré et accentué l'eau ceux ci on
sait que tous les gouvernements à
travers le monde le nom est inclus ici
aux etats-unis encore plus son ont
débloqué des montants d'argent donc ce
que ça fait sale on monte encore on les
déficits et la dette
encore plus et l'offre toujours été une
valeur refuge à ce moment là quel impact
pour vous est-ce que vous allez investir
davantage et vu que vu une augmentation
du dividende mais est-ce que vous allez
appuyer sur l'accélérateur
on n'avait pas vraiment de grands
investissements qui était prévu avant
tout chauds d'été prévus et se serait
produit 1 carmen parce qu'on fait toutes
nos études avec des prix de l'ordre sont
beaucoup plus beau que qu'à l'heure
actuelle
donc pour vous donner un exemple on fait
toutes nos études environ 250 dollars
l'once
donc l'aurait quoi 700 $ de plus
maintenant que ce donc nous nos projets
étaient déjà très très rentable on a des
investissements qui ont été annoncées à
notre mine
giacobbi nord au brésil que kiki qui
revendent décisions qui vont être pris
en étant l'étude de faisabilité présent
mais les études de préfaisabilité ô mon
truc c'était très économique de 1 faible
investissement
donc ça ça va se produire à malartic qui
n'a plus grosse opération pour nous avec
notre notre partenaire
on a annoncé la semaine passée notre
partenaire annoncé cette semaine qu'ont
commencé les travaux pour aller super
donc c'était une mine en surface à scier
du bois se transformera avec le temps
chasser des investissements assez
important pendant les prochaines années
mais à partir de 2 ans et demi à trois
ans si c'est un investissement très
important
plus loin on pourrait vu plus de moyens
c'est ça oui ma court terme du moins à
court terme c à court terme c'est
vraiment un abîme giacobino et
l'exploration cession' endroit qu'on ne
mais plus d'argent avec l'augmentation
du prix de lancer l'exploitation et les
dividendes comme cela est mentionné
alors la pandémie arrêtez vos activités
certains traits ce que ça fragilise
parce que vous avez parlé notamment du
brésil
est-ce que ça fragilise vos activités
que ce soit ici ou à l'international
n'ont été arrêté ici au québec que trois
semaines parce que le gouvernement nous
l'a demandé par contre la menor la
partie au moins de recul comme c'était
avant
malgré toutes les procédures qu'on a dû
mettre en place des votes raybier ont
été arrêtés ou en argentine la même
chose mon chili au brésil on eu aucun
arrêt faut dire que dans le domaine mini
on est assez changé nos vies nos mines
sont très loin des grands soirs où ce
qui est concentrée principalement vous
avez vous parlé du baiser le csao paulo
c'est riou qui sont des villes où ce qui
a énormément de corps mais où on est à
bahia giacobbi n'a et il n'y a pas de
quoi donc cesser plus c'est plus facile
c'est la même chose ici vous allez à val
d'or à malartic en abitibi pas de quoi
donc on est loin de montréal
donc ça ne va pas ou peu affecter
nouveau chili est un briseur nom n'a pas
d'histoire et on a conçu une opv même
c'est maintenant surperformer cas par
rapport à ce qu'on s'attendait depuis le
mois de mars est en train de seconde que
vous avez parlé notamment de malartic en
termine un peu cette image des grosses
entreprises aurifères qui exploite deux
gisements parfois cette communauté et
que ça m'a tout au far west
comment dois je maintenant avec les
communautés notamment le girard est
votre gisement à malartic bas depuis
qu'on est propriétaire depuis juin 2014
on a mis des politiques en place pour
pour compenser des désagréments causés
par la mienne on eu beaucoup de
discussions avec eux en un comité de
citoyens avec lequel on discute on a un
bureau dans la ville de mars et plus les
gens peuvent venir s'exprimer donc ça ça
va très très bien nous vous savez quand
on respecte tout ce qu'on demande au
niveau de l'environnement du bruit à des
projets hamas a fait décide facilite
beaucoup et à des discussions avec nos
partenaires qui sont les citoyens de
malartic davantage de coopération de la
finale
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci